here's a big mean cultural icon all
sorts of stories get printed about you
so last week Warren Beatty's here and we
did the thing with him where we just
read out some of the mad stories that
have been in the papers among them over
the years this could be fun and just
kind of read your expressions will be
camera very close on your faders I read
these out you're just trying page from
your pace you're young your face moves
so let's see are you ready for this the
Warren Beatty
deadpan challenge you took a carrot cake
to a seat would Mac concert that's yes
yeah is there yet but idiot let it take
a carrot cake this look like I like
carrot cake I'm single Mac hopefully
love you and Liam got chlamydia from a
koala bear in you what confirm that's
not true okay you were thinking of
becoming in a state agent okay set your
face for this one I really want to see
this one okay okay you have a sexual
relationship with Barack Obama
wavering affair legally not allowed to
say you want to be a picture of him I've
done it so you keep your skin and check
with cheap percenter it's not true okay
and finally you auditioned to be the new
Han Solo why love you yes so far I think
that's a yes amazing it's like with it
you just slide over they do here
[Music]